>> Tucker: IF YOU'VE GOT A
TELEVISION SET IN YOUR HOUSE,
YOU KNOW WELL THAT THE MEDIA HAS
BEEN CELEBRATING THE CREEPY PORN
LAWYER AS A HERO FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS.
TURNS OUT THEY ARE ACTIVELY
HELPING HIM BY HOLDING BACK
DAMAGING INFORMATION ABOUT HIM
FROM YOU, THE PUBLIC.
THE CREEPY PORN LAWYER SAID THAT
DEMOCRATS ABSOLUTELY NEED TO
ELECT A WHITE MAN IN 2020.
NOTHING THAT WOULD HARM THE
DEMOCRATS MORE IN THAT PHRASE.
TIME MAGAZINE DID NOT TELL YOU
THAT.
THEY DID NOT KNOW FOR MONTHS
BECAUSE THEY SAT ON THE STORY.
MEANWHILE, CREEPY PORN LAWYER
BECAME A NATIONAL FIGURE.
WHEN CREEPY PORN LAWYER AND HIS
CLIENT ACCUSED BRETT KAVANAUGH
OF DISSIPATING IN A LONG SERIES
OF PUBLIC GANG RAPES, REMEMBER
THAT, PRODUCED A STATEMENT THAT
SEEMED TO BACK UP SOME OF HER
CLAIMS.
YOU VAGUELY REPAIR
REMEMBER THIS.
WEEKS LATER, THE WOMAN RECANTED
THE STORY TO NBC NEWS REPORTERS.
SHE QUOTED THAT CPL "TWISTED HER
WORDS."
CBS NEWS HAD INFORMATION THAT
UNDERMINED ACCUSATION AGAINST
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
IT WOULD BE NICE TO KNOW THAT
BEFORE THE VOTE, BUT THEY DIDN'T
TELL ANYBODY.
ARE YOU SURPRISED?
ONLY IF YOU IMAGINE NBC NEWS WAS
STILL A NEWS ORGANIZATION AND
NOT A PARTICULARLY CLUMSY ARM OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHICH IS THEY ARE BECAUSE IT WAS
NBC THAT LEAKED THE AXES
HOLLYWOOD TAPES TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" BEFORE THE
GENERAL TO INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME
OF THAT ELECTION AND --
THEY DID ALL THAT.
IT WASN'T ENOUGH FOR CREEPY PORN
LAWYER.
EVEN WITH NBC'S ASSISTANCE, HIS
CLIENT STORMY DANIELS WAS
ORDERED TO PAY DONALD TRUMP'S
LEGAL FEES.
NOT A LAW FIRM THAT HE RUNS IS
FACING EVICTION FOR FAILING TO
PAY HIS RENT.
HE STILL WANTED THE BEST KNOWN
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES FOR
PRESIDENT, THOUGH.
HOW IS HE LIKELY TO DO?
CHRIS OGDEN IS A PROGRESSIVE --
HE JOINS US FROM LONG ISLAND FOR
A CREEPY PORN LAWYER UPDATE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: HERE'S MY THEORY.
CREEPY PORN LAWYER MAKES
BASELESS CHARGES AGAINST MATT
CAVANAUGH, CHARGES HIM IN
PARTICIPATING A RAPE, AND NOT
ONE DEMOCRAT CRITICIZES HIM
UNTIL HE ENDORSES THE IDEA OF
A WHITE MAN RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT UNTIL ALL DEMOCRATS
SAY THIS IS OVER.
WHY DIDN'T ANYBODY NOTE THAT
BEFORE?
>> HOLD ON A MINUTE.
I HAVE CRITICIZED HIM ON THIS
NETWORK SEVERAL TIMES AND SAID
HE'LL NEVER BE THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE FOR PRESIDENT.
I LOVE HIS HAIRCUT AND IT'S
FANTASTIC AND VERY EFFICIENT BUT
I'VE CRITICIZED HIM POLITICALLY.
I THINK HE'S THE REASON WHY
SUSAN COLLINS VOTED FOR BRETT
KAVANAUGH BECAUSE I THOUGHT THE
SWEATNIK ALLEGATIONS WERE
OUTRAGEOUS AND HARD TO PROVE,
THAT SAID HE HAD AN AFFIDAVIT
FROM A CLIENT.
HE WAS NOT DEFAMING KAVANAUGH.
IT WAS THE CLIENT.
LOOK, THERE ARE LOTS OF
PROBLEMS --
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH YOU
UNTIL THEY ARE.
I CAN'T LET YOU AWAY WITH THE
LAWYER DODDS THAT IT'S THE
CLIENT.
IT WAS CREEPY PORN LAWYER WHO
TOOK THE DEPOSITION WHO WAS THE
VEHICLE BY WHICH THE REST OF US
KNEW THAT THESE ALLEGATIONS WERE
MADE.
BY THE WAY, THESE ALLEGATIONS
ARE TAKEN WITH DEAD SERIOUSNESS
BY EVERY NEWS ORGANIZATION IN
THE NATION, THAT THEY SHOW, AND
DEMOCRATS NEVER SAY, WAIT A
MINUTE, 10 GANG RAPES IN A ROW?
DEMOCRATS STOOD AND THEY NODDED,
THAT'S VERY SERIOUS.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE TOOK AT LESS
THAN SERIOUS AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
DISMISSED IT AND THOUGHT THIS
WAS ADDING SOMETHING TO WHAT WAS
SOME VERY CREDIBLE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST KAVANAUGH.
LOOK, WE CALL THEM CREEPY PORN
LAWYER BECAUSE HE REPRESENTED A
STAR WHO WE KNOW WAS PAID DID
NOT DISCUSS HER AFFAIR WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: CAN I JUST ASK YOU
A QUESTION?
SHE TOOK MONEY FOR A VOLUNTARY
RELATIONSHIP IN EXCHANGE FOR NOT
TALKING ABOUT IT.
WE USED TO CALL THAT EXTORTION.
BUT NOW WE ARE TOTALLY COOL WITH
IT AND WE ARE BLAMING THE GUY
WHO HAD TO PAY THE EXTORTION
MONEY?
HOW DOES THAT WORK EXACTLY?
ARE WE FOR THAT NOW?
>> WE ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW THE MONEY WAS
PROPOSED.
IN FACT, IT COULD'VE BEEN
PROPOSED BY THE PERSON WHO
WANTED TO COVER IT UP, NOT
NECESSARILY THE PORN STAR.
WE NEVER GOT TO THE BOTTOM OF
THAT.
THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS SETTLED
THE MATTER SO I THINK THEY WERE
HAPPY WITH THE ARRANGEMENT.
>> Tucker: THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IT SO THEY MUST BE
GUILTY, BUT YOU ARE TOTALLY COOL
IF PEOPLE HAVE A CONSENSUAL, AND
RELATIONSHIP AND ONE OF THEM
GIVES MONEY ENOUGH TO TALK ABOUT
IT --
>> I'M NOT.
>> Tucker: WHERE IS THAT?
>> I AM NOT IN FAVOR OF
EXTORTION.
I WAS JUST POINTING OUT YOUR
CALLING HIM A PORN LAWYER.
WE KNOW WHY WE CALL HIM A PORN
LAWYER.
WE HAVE TO KNOW WHY WE CALL HIM
A PORN LAWYER.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE WAS TRYING TO